la mort 2e partie deuxième segment de
notre édition spéciale prospective 2020
de rdi économie avec vincent delisle
richard ouellet tehani chalus a ni
jaloux le message de monsieur goûter res
est extrêmement clair et très très
puissant
est-ce que 2020 sera l'année de ce
virage qui est un temps souhaité tente
appelé je pense que ça doit être l'année
charnière parce que il reste très peu de
temps si on veut répondre aux objectifs
que l'accord de paris s'était donné
c'est à dire d'atteindre nos objectifs
d'environ 1.5 degrés d'ici la fin du
siècle et les émissions ne font
qu'augmenter
est ce que ce qu'on voit là avec le la
coop 25,6 qu il ya énormément de choses
que les pays doivent entreprendre
internationalement que ce soit sur la
transparence que les pays doivent
réduire aussi la rémission rehausser
leur ambition est aussi qu'est ce qu'on
fait avec les pays les plus vulnérables
donc on doit faire plein de choses
rapidement et ça doit bouger assez vite
alors à coke 25 c'est la conférence des
parties qui avaient lieu avant les fêtes
sur l'environnement qui rassemble 2 bien
sûr tous les pays le canada il y aura
des décisions de court aussi qu'on va
surveiller en 2020 pascal contestation
de la tarification du carbone
oui tout à fait ça va être un moment
charnière au canada pour ces raisons là
au printemps on devrait entendre
notamment les le cas de l'ontario et de
la saskatchewan qui vont permettre de
voir et une fois le jugement rendu c'est
le fédéral aux compétences en matière de
tarification carbone au pays et si la
réponse est oui et donc on entérine les
jugements des tribunaux en ferrain
inférieur ça va être très important
parce que ça va donner des outils
supplémentaires au fédéral pour mettre
un prix réel sur le carbone et
éventuellement tendre à atteindre nos
engagements prévus pour 2030
est ce que richard ouellet
union des pays s'effraient un peu depuis
l'accord de paris oui l'union s'effrite
et la mondialisation est en train de
s'écrire est né ce que j'entends par là
c'est que maintenant les accords de
libre échange on ne les fait plus autour
de l'om c'est à 164 on ne les fait plus
grand nombre on les fait par 3 par
groupe de trois par groupes de 12
et ça c'est pas utile pour combattre des
phénomènes comme le réchauffement
climatique
ce que la mondialisation doit nous
ramener et c'est une urgence c'est la
capacité de prendre des décisions
collectivement des décisions
multilatérale qui affecte l'ensemble de
la planète et de ce point de vue là la
mondialisation économique et inquiétante
parce qu'elles n'offrent pas le bon
forum pour ensuite s'attaquer aux enjeux
qui sont une priorité
moi j'ai beau être un prof de droit
international économique jeudi
régulièrement mes étudiants que la
priorité en est une barre environnement
il faut que le contexte économique
permettent des prises de décisions
environnementales qui tiennent compte de
l'urgence les entreprises et les
investisseurs au sens large sont ils
prêts à cela il faut qu'il le soir
lorsque le défi écologique quand on le
met sur la scène des marchés
l'économiste un défi majeur parce que ce
soit des pays qui ne s'attend plus à 100
ou des entreprises et en équipe et en
amérique à l apprenez juste le canada
par exemple avec beaucoup plus
réfractaires dans l'ouest on le comprend
beaucoup plus beaucoup plus d'énergie
d'énergies fossiles à skis ski ce qui
s'organise dans le monde des affaires
sur les marchés c'est d'une part ça
prend des règles que ça prend des
chiffes s'apprend les entreprises
doivent être imputables on doit parler
de chiffres on se comprend pour savoir
nous avons amélioré nous avons
détériorer notre notre performance
environnementale et du côté des
investisseurs tout
la popularité grandissante de
l'investissement responsable nous gérons
des fonds chez nous et nous avait ça
nous le demandent comment pouvons-nous
s'assurer qu'on parle qu'on va avec avec
notre argent mais le défi économique y
est important il des secteurs qui vont
sont à risque et des secteurs qui
doivent contre les et dépôt effectué la
transition alors qu'il y en a d'autres
qui vont en profiter mais si on vend le
défi écologique comme une opportunité
plutôt qu'une contrainte
je pense que ça va accélérer
l'acceptation mondiale
on préfère être du côté de l'opportunité
que du côté de la contrainte clairement
ils font du côté de l'opportunité que
moi ok vincent delisle je continue avec
vous sur la récession ont je me suis
retenu que dire le mot récession parce
qu'on a tout le temps l'impression que
c'est nous qui en parlons plutôt que la
réalité mais l'été passé les courbes de
romain nous disait recession récession
récession
on en est aux feux naissants de cette
année vous et moi on a fait quelques
émissions spéciales sur la récession à
l'été dernier puis j'ai dit en souriant
parce que c'est un des indicateurs que
j'utilise indicateurs contrarié
lorsqu'on en parle beaucoup
habituellement ce soit reflétée dans le
prix où ça n'arrivera pas en 2010
d'accueil au ralentissement économique
majeur d'un secteur industriel
on l'a pas vu dans les dépenses de
consommation dieu soit loué parce que
l'économie mondiale
c'est la consommation et banque centrale
se sont ajustés très rapide maillot eu
des baisses de taux préventive trois
baisses de taux aux etats unis les
gouvernements le japon a récemment
annoncé des mesures de stimulation milly
fiscaux ça fait longtemps que le japon
n'a pas investi dans son économie alors
je pense qu'on a le fait juste assez
pour éviter que la douleur d'un secteur
industriel se répandent
du côté des dépenses de consommation
donc peu de risque de récession
en 2020 on pense que l'économie la
visibilité de ligue mondiale devrait
s'améliorer en deuxième moitié d'année
prochaine
la visibilité est bonne comme dirait des
gens de transports québec
ok très bien fait s'il ya quelqu'un qui
a été occupée en 2019
c'est guy cornou le pdg de desjardins
on a rapidement constaté qu'un employé
du mouvement desjardins a agi de façon
illégale en trahissant la confiance de
desjardins est ce que nos données
est ce qu'on vient de se réveiller sur
la protection de nous donner
c'est sûr que cet événement là était un
réveil important il ya la question de la
sécurité mais il ya aussi la question de
tout ce qui est légal mais qui échappe à
vous et moi on ne sait pas jusqu'à quel
point les données que nous mettons sur
internet nous échappe désormais peut
faire l'objet de commerce
alors on va au devant d'un vaste choc
l'union européenne en termes de
relations internationales l'union
européenne a adopté un modèle
extrêmement protecteurs du consommateur
notamment et du citoyen en général et en
amérique du nord nous sommes un peu
encore à la traîne et on n'a pas
beaucoup de règles qui protègent
tellement le citoyen qui met ses données
sur facebook sur instagram ou je ne sais
trop quelle plateforme et il va falloir
un moment donné qu'on réussisse à faire
une certaine harmonisation par exemple
ce droit à l'oubli les européens
s'imaginent qu'ils ont un droit à
l'oubli alors quand on retire des
données sur internet nous sommes
désormais protéger ce droit à l'oubli et
leveaux sur le territoire européen
alors dans une société complètement
virtuel complètement informatique et
numérique
ce droit à l'oubli ne vaut pas grand
chose ici en amérique du nord il va
falloir qu'on arrive à mieux et dans un
avenir rapproché
ouais c'est quand même fascinant parce
que dans les dernières années on a eu
facebook plus chez nous au québec on a
eu des jardins bien sûr avec ce qui
s'est passé deux types de données un peu
différent mais des données quand même
des éléments d'identification qui nous
appartiennent et qui peuvent circuler
normalement
on va terminer mission sur vos
suggestions de livres à chaque année on
vous suggère dé des lectures
intéressantes de la part de nos experts
invités on va commencer tout de suite
avec un michel loup qui a qui veut nous
parler d'hydro-québec
oui un très beau livre qui est paru
cette année pour célébrer le 75e
anniversaire d'hydro-québec
c'est donc deux chroniqueurs qui ont
créé cet ouvrage à qui son ouvrage qui
fait du bien qui nous rappelle un peu
que on peut être fier aussi au québec
d'avoir une telle société d'état on est
parti de très loin
en sur le plan économique cela nous a
permis de grandir énormément comme
société et que cette société d'état là
elle est aussi un pilier qu'on peut
utiliser pour les politiques
environnementales de l'avenir que ce
soit pour l'exportation d'énergie est
générale et donc on a un outil on a un
instrument au québec qui est très
prometteur si on veut amorcer une
transition énergétique et cet ouvrage a
fait du bien nous fait pas juste vivre
un cynisme par rapport à la société
d'état ou par rapport à l'intervention
l'interventionnisme économique de notre
état donc ça fait vraiment du bien je le
recommande fortement
c'est à dire que des fois on oublie des
tarifs l'appui on peut passer
l'impact sur l'ensemble de la société
elle socio-économique d'hydro-québec
vous diriez j'aime hydro en vous les
chars ouellette vous avez deux
suggestions
oui alors je ne sais pas si mes
suggestions font du bien en tout cas
elle bouscule un peu les idées
un premier livre que j'ai ici la fin du
leadership américain est l état du monde
20 20 c'est sous la direction de
bertrand badie qui est un immense
politologue que tout le monde connaît
dans cet ouvrage là on essaie de voir
dans quelle mesure les américains ont
été les leaders de la mondialisation et
renonce aujourd'hui à ce rôle et on
attend de voir quels sont les impacts de
ce renoncement des américains vers quoi
va-t-on un deuxième ouvrage qui lui a
été écrit par dani rodrik qui s'intitule
la mondialisation sur la sellette
plaidoyer pour une économie saine c'est
le sous titre dans cet ouvrage la
dernière brique qui est un économiste je
dirais de centre gauche critiquent
vertement à la mondialisation mais en
même temps ne prône pas du tout un
retour au protectionniste
protectionnisme pardon il prône plutôt
un retour vers une mondialisation plus
équilibrée où les états gardent la
capacité de prendre des politiques
publiques fortes pour plan social au
plan environnemental
donc il est un peu à mi chemin entre les
deux extrêmes que l'on voit trop souvent
aujourd'hui le discours public présent
donné peu de propositions
mon livre s'appelle une brève histoire
de l'avenir de jacques attali dans sept
ans est un livre qu'avant de réflexion
sur l'avenir du monde vit on inspecte
socio économique
la vision de l'avenir de l'auteur est
intéressante parce que j'ai trouvé
beaucoup plus enrichissant c'est qu'on
fait un retour en arrière jusqu'au moyen
âge on passe à travers les principaux
centres économiques mondiaux dont le
pistolet 7/4 économique alors on parle
de l'italie
amsterdam anvers on voit à londres ont
traversé l'atlantique et ce qui est
intéressant c'est de voir que ce qui est
fait en sorte qu'il y ait eu ces pôles
économiques là à travers les années à
travers le siècle c'est des richesses en
ressources naturelles mais de la
nouvelle technologie alors plus ça
change plus c'est pareil c'est très
intéressant avec la guerre que se
livrent actuellement les américains et
la chine ou le pôle sans avoir des états
unis probablement vers l'asie dont la
chine
merci beaucoup très intéressant vincent
delisle et de charger des t1 et chalus
merci beaucoup d'avoir participé à cette
émission
merci bien les suggestions de livres je
vous le mentionne tout de suite sont sur
notre page facebook d'ailleurs tous nos
contenus sont disponibles sur
facebook.com barres obliques rdi
économie on se retrouve sur twitter sur
youtube et sur radio canada.ca barres
obliques rdi économie
c'est ce qui m'est fait cette édition
spéciale de rdi économie j'espère que
vous avez apprécié je vous souhaite une
bonne année bonne année à vous aussi
d'ailleurs
merci bien et à l'an prochain
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]